can you imagine today one of the FAQs  you got to give to a parent is what's a  transgender and am I one am I being my  gay am I lesbian hey Mommy let me ask  you a question why did you not take the  vaccine why are we taking a vaccine my  teacher told me it's irresponsible to  not take the vaccine are we taking a  vaccine the FAQ of parenting today is  the size of a Bible and parents just  can't keep up anymore that's the biggest  in my opinion that's the biggest  difference of parenting in the 80s  versus today it's like in the 80s you  needed an associate degree to be a  parent today you need a PhD to be a  parent wow you need to go train to learn  how to answer somebody's complex  questions with kids it's a challenge  attempt to have kids I think